في مقاله لصحيفه واشنطن بوست كتب ايشان
ثرور ان حماس شديده التحصين ومن الصعب
هزيمتها وحتى مع شنها واحده من اكثر
الحملات العسكريه عنفا في التاريخ الحديث
لم تتمكن اسرائيل يضيف الكاتب من التاثير
سوى في جزء بسيط من قدره حماس العسكريه
لكنها تمكنت في المقابل من تدمير قطاع غزه
المحاصر وتشريد نحو 90% من سكانه وهي تخبط
اليوم في معركه تخسر فيها الراي العام
العالمي في مجله ايكونوميست نجد ان
اسرائيل لا تعرف بالضبط ما الذي يتعين
عليها فعله فيما يتعلق بازمه الرهائن امام
خيارات محفوفه بالمخاطر مضيفه ان موقف
الحكومه من المفاوضات يبدو
مرتبكا المجله تعود الى حادثه مقتل
الرهائن الثلاث بنيران قوات الجيش
الاسرائيلي وتعلق بالقول انها تعكس حقيقه
ان اسرائيل عاجزه عن التوفيق بين اهدافها
في حربها على حماس اكثر من اي وقت
مضى توقع مقال في صحيفتها ارتس ان يبدا
نطاق رفض الحرب بين الاسرائيليين في
التوسع ليشمل اكثر مؤيديها قريبا يلفت
المقال الى ان الشكوك بدات تتسرب الى
الجمهور الاسرائيلي بخصوص واقعيه اهداف
الحرب حتى ان انصار مواصله القتال لا
يشعرون كثيرا بالرضا او تحقق انجازات
ملموسه خلص المقال الى ان الغضب والصدمه
من هجوم السابع من اكتوبر غير كافيين
لضمان الدعم الشعبي لحرب دمويه طويله
الامد في صحيفه جيروساليم بوست مقال يتوقع
زلزالا سياسيا كبيرا في اسرائيل بعد هجوم
حماس ويرى ان ما حدث تسبب في تحول جذري في
المشهد السياسي في
اسرائيل يصف المقال الوضع بالقول ان ثقه
البلاد بنفسها تضررت واهتز الاحساس
بالامان وتحطمت الثقه بالقاده السياسيين
والعسكريين ويضيف ان تشكيله الاحزاب التي
ستتنافس في الانتخابات المقبله ستكون
مختلفه تماما عن المشهد في الانتخابات
الاخيره انتقد تقرير في صحيفه لوموند
استهداف قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي لمستشفيات
غزه الواحده تلو الاخر متسببا بذلك في
خسائر بشريه وماديه لا حصر لها يروي
التقرير قصص بعض المستشفيات والمراكز
الصحيه التي تعرضت للقصف ثم يستنتج ان حجم
الدمار والضرر الذي لحق بسكان غزه من مساع
اسرائيل لملاحقه مقاتلي حماس وجمع
المعلومات عنهم لا يتناسبان مع النتائج
التي اعلن الجيش
عنها تناول تقرير في صحيفه تليغراف مساعي
المسؤولين الامريكيين لردع الحوثيين
وتامين مرور سفن الشحن عبر البحر الاحمر
وذكر ان مستشارين بالبنتاغون حذروا من ان
تنفيذ ضربات مباشره ضد اهداف لهم في اليمن
قد يؤدي الى تاجيج التوترات مع ايران كما
يشعر مسؤولو البنتاجون وفق التقرير بالقلق
بشان تكلفه عمليتهم الدفاعيه في البحر
الاحمر